Congressman Jim
Jordan's crusade
against the DOJ and FBI showing
signs of falling apart.
Jordan has long
promised a major investigation
into the agency's
political bias as he sees it.
But tonight,
there are growing questions
about the witnesses
who are central to his case.
This is Republicans
like Matt Gates are using
the topic as red meat for the base.
Here he is just today
We have been taking
whistleblower testimony
from brave patriots,
people who worked at the FBI.
And I don't care
if it takes every second of our time
and every ounce of our energy,
we either get this government
back on our side
or we defund and get rid of abolish
the FBI, CDC, ATF,
DOJ, every last one of us.
Sara Murray is OUTFRONT
House Judiciary Chair Jim
Jordan pinning his probe
into alleged political bias
at the Justice Department
and the FBI on unnamed whistleblowers.
This is dozens of FBI whistleblowers
coming to talk to us.
We expect
more whistleblowers to come forward
and set for these depositions.
But after three of them sat
for private interviews,
with committee staff,
Democrats are questioning
their legitimacy
as actual whistleblowers
and the relevance of their testimony.
You just said dozens are
you do have notes from those
or they're just talking to you, to
your chair.
None of the three appear
to have had their claims
validated by government entities
that grant federal
whistleblower protection, sources
tell CNN.
One of the GOP
whistleblowers is former
FBI agent Steve Friend.
I don't think you have to be
a nonpartisan if you are a partizan to
to come to the conclusion
that the FBI has clearly prioritized
this January six investigation
and is willing to put the public safety
at risk.
He says he was
suspended for objecting to a SWAT
raid of a January six
suspect facing arrest
for misdemeanor offenses.
But the suspect was seen at the Capitol
on January
six with an air style rifle
and tactical military gear.
According to court records,
Still, Friend told CNN, quote,
I compared it to using an elephant gun
to kill a mouse.
He filed whistleblower complaint
with the DOJ's inspector general
and the U.S. Office of Special Counsel.
Both officers
eventually rejected his claims.
Another whistleblower, Jordan,
is leaning on for his probe.
Former FBI analyst George Hill,
who has tweeted insurrection my ass.
It was a setup
about the attack on the Capitol.
He claimed the FBI tried to open cases
into people
merely for traveling to the Capitol
on January six.
We're not opening up
cases for people that were going down
to a political rally.
House Judiciary Democrats
concluded Hill's testimony is marred
by substantial
bias and lacks
any real hallmarks of credibility.
And an FBI spokesperson said
the FBI will never open an investigation
based solely on First
Amendment protected activity.
A nonprofit group
representing Hill told CNN to wait
for the official transcript, quote,
before reporting on selective
partizan leaks.
A third GOP
whistleblower, Garett
O'Boyle, says he was suspended
from the FBI
and stripped of his security clearance
after allegedly making an unauthorized
media disclosure a claim he denies.
He described
this as being a weaponization
of the security clearance process,
according to the Democratic staff report.
But on many points,
he refused to elaborate or offer
Democrats corroborating evidence.
His attorney,
a former election attorney
for Donald
Trump,
told CNN
his client provided
confidential information to Congress,
but he did not release
that information
to Democrats on the committee
because he knew that they would leaked
to the media
Delegate Stacey Plaskett,
the top Democrat
on the so-called weaponization
committee, tells CNN.
I said at the outset that I thought
that this was a mechanism
for them to float
every conspiracy theory
that they might want to try and utilize
in the 20, 24 election.
And it appears like that's,
in fact, the case.
A spokesperson for Jordan in a statement
accused Democrats of leaking
Cherry picked excerpts of testimony
to attack the brave whistleblowers
who risked their careers
to speak out on abuses
at the Justice Department and FBI.
Now, an FBI
spokesperson tells CNN when FBI employees
report actual evidence of wrongdoing,
they are protected from retaliation.
We are also learning
there are several other
supposed whistleblowers
who have yet to come in
with interviews with the committee,
including some
who were suspended from the FBI
for attending demonstrations
at the Capitol on January six, sources
tell CNN.
And Jordan has not back down
from that point, Aaron.
He's previously
accused the FBI
of retaliating against employees
for taking part
in First Amendment activity.
All right, sir, thank you very much.
And I want to go now to Ryan Goodman.
So, Ryan,
you hear Sarah's reporting going through.
You know, the three people
who have testified
obviously can't use
the word whistleblowers.
Jordan says there's there's dozens more
I guess what
I am wondering here
is that
Jim Jordan really loves this topic.
So if Jim Jordan had the good,
he would be wanting
to make this public, right?
He wouldn't be like, why are you leaking?
Be public. It be televised.
And what does this all say?
The way it's being handled
about what he's really got?
Right. That's a great question.
If these people have
the goods, let's hear it.
And in fact,
in the over 300 page
Democratic staff report,
they actually have a forward
by the ranking members
from the Democratic side
that actually say
present these individuals
to the American public without delay.
We want
we want to hear from them
because they do not have the goods.
They are not whistleblowers.
They do not have any firsthand
information about fraud, waste and abuse,
the technical terms
for being a whistleblower.
So it doesn't seem like he has it,
at least
with the three people
that have actually gone
before the subcommittee. Right.
I mean, just again, to make the point is
everybody should be aware
if Jim Jordan had it,
he would be blasting it.
He wouldn't be upset
that somebody was leaking it.
So just it's just a very basic
kind of gut check here now.
Steve Friend,
one of the whistleblowers
that we saw, the sound bite from him
on Fox News at Zero Share.
He's a former FBI agent in Florida.
He was suspended last year
for objecting to that SWAT raid
of a suspect
who had been at January six
and had an AR 15 style rifle.
So what do you make of that situation?
So it's
also like not
the poster child one once
if you're thinking
that these people are whistleblowers.
So the idea from Jim Jordan is
this is a conscientious objector,
but now we find out
what did he object to?
He resisted and refused to assist the FBI
in its SWAT arrest of this individual
who is an alleged three percenter
militia member.
And in fact,
they were called the B squad,
and they're featured in the final report
by the January six committee
because they engage in the assault
on the Capitol and in fact, under attack,
soon to be armed,
somebody known to be armed and dangerous.
And in fact,
under Testa, in his testimony, Friend
then admits
that he was known
to be armed and dangerous
and then that would qualify
for a SWAT operation.
So it just all falls apart.
He admits that qualifies,
but he didn't do it and wants
conscientious objector status
doesn't add up. Exactly.
All right, Ryan
Goodman, thank you very much.